foreign
had somebody pop into my DMs as you guys
sometimes do and she was like Jade
you've got to see this and so I click
open the email and
it's a ad for
a company called lint table and so I
opened it up and I look at it and it
basically says you can't afford to for
to fund your 401k
let us do it for you
lint table we will loan you the money
to invest into your 401k up to your
match so that you can get your company
match and then we've magically solved
all your problems here except for a
couple of problems here so just to make
this clear crystal clear you're a person
you work at your job you get a three
percent match but because you're broke
you're broke you're not on a budget
you're spending all your money you say I
don't have any money to invest in my
401k and everybody's telling me I you
know need to do it so I'm going to go to
lendtable and they're going to loan me
the money the three percent the three
percent so they give you six thousand
dollars or whatever it is you and you
invent you take that money give it to
your employer they invest it and then
they match it but here's the catch and
let me tell you it's a catch it says
once approved you can link your company
sponsored retirement account with your
bank and we will disburse the payments
you charge ten dollars a month so this
is a subscription service so you're
paying ten dollars a month 120 a year
and you sign your contract now from that
on they're they're putting the money in
and meeting the match for you now here's
the kicker and this is the one that gets
me if you leave your job so let's just
say you win you leave yeah when you
leave your job now you don't just have
to be fired if you decide to move on die
you retire you take a better job yeah
you you are on the hook for everything
that they've lended you up until that
point Dave what if you did this for like
four or five years that's a lot of money
it could end up being substantial
substantial and not only that here's
where I'm like you guys they take 20
of your earnings
twenty percent twenty percent of what
the employer match is and twenty percent
of what it goes up yes
so was it worth it so so let me get this
straight this is a credit card yeah that
charges you a 120 annual fee and a 20
interest rate and
it's tied to your 401k and really
screwing up your life when you leave
your company well it gets worse because
you have to write a check for the whole
thing right then and if you can't guess
what
you're going to be cashing out the 401K
or borrowing on the 401K or screwing up
the 401K there's so many stupid things
here for you to do in one possible thing
and it's all bad for you and all good
for them well I love that it says hey if
you choose to you can just repay Us by
getting a 401k withdrawal a 401k loan
you know what I'll bet you that I bet
your end table will issue one of their
credit cards and uh you can move the
money over to there and that's probably
only 28 percent
you know the thing that occurred to me
when I saw that I thought I wonder what
the table is I I just watched the uh you
know if you're seeing the John Wick
movies no Dave John Wick the evil the
evil empire in the John Wick movies is a
thing called the table the mafia
organization in the background of these
Hit Men okay it's called the table okay
and if you want to be an assassin for
the table you have to like give up a
finger or whatever okay you have to
prove your commitment right I'm tracking
the table however will turn on you
that's why they call the tables turned
that's why they call that so oh wow okay
and so the table it's and that's what I
thought of when I saw this you're going
to give up a finger this is like this is
like eight digits
okay you're drawing nub back oh my gosh
at the very least they should leave you
the middle one because that's what
you're gonna that's what you want to
give them oh oh you couldn't just leave
it with them as a permanent sign of our
affection oh man
it's terrible
so you're gonna borrow at 20 of what the
employer pays you and ten dollars and
any gains and ten dollars a month 120 a
year in order to get the employer match
because you're too broke to get the
matching stupid stuff that's What Makes
You Broke
stupid butt stuff makes you broke and
this fault Lin table let me help you
guys this falls under the heading of
stupid butt stuff so real stupid I think
you and I just made new friends over at
Lynn table yeah I love Jade and Dave now
well I don't like when they screw people
I don't like that I don't like products
that benefit from other people's bondage
I hate that I I hate that there's no
upside for the customers there's all
outside for Lindy table and and and and
they're they're taking advantage of the
fact that they and and you're buying
into it when you do this when when
companies make products based on the
fact of you're probably not going to
make more money at the end yeah
same job oh gosh who stays at the same
job you're gonna have a cash crunch
right you have a problem yeah because
you know it's like it's like borrowing
on your 401k in that sense because when
you leave your company there that's why
we tell you not to borrow on your 401k
because you get yourself in a crack man
it's bad news yeah horrible stuff